all right good afternoon everyone thanks
for joining us today it's great to see
so many of you as you can see I hope
it's clear on the screen we're having a
look at something which sounds very big
and intimidating the fundamental theorem
of calculus but I promise by the end of
this this is actually going to become
one of your best friends it's a really
amazing piece of mathematics now if you
have a look at something with a
fundamental theorem of calculus and
you're like go and look it up online
like if you go to that faithful friend
of every person who's tried to do an
assignment last minute and head on to
Wikipedia and the fundamental theorem of
calculus page on Wikipedia is very full
there's a lot happening when you start
to read the top of it it's not too bad I
mean for example but basing off um you
know mrs. Liza's lesson that she gave us
before there is a fair bit of history
here and you might look at that first
sentence and think oh the fundamental
theorem of calculus relates
differentiation and integration I know
what both of those are so far so good
but things rapidly go south if you have
a look even just a little bit down the
page and you have a look at some of this
awful notation here some of which you
recognize but others of which you like I
have no idea what's happening it is just
like generally confusing and you can
understand why that is because the
fundamental theorem of calculus as the
name suggests is something which lays at
the foundation of so much of what we do
in mathematics a lot of things that
we've been talking about in the news
actually just people haven't been using
all of the specific language for it and
so rather than give you kind of you know
notation soup and make you very confused
I want to actually use the news as our
starting point for you know why does
this piece of mathematics matter for us
and how can actually help us understand
the world and solve problems so to that
end I've got a little graph for all of
you to have a look at now I should
stress all of this is made-up numbers I
mean they're not completely made up
those numbers on the left hand side of
the graph the last thing I checked I
think it was something like five
thousand eight hundred and those days
since the first confirmed case in
Australia I think the first confirmed
case was around late January so you know
we're in
Apryl now we're around a 67 68 so apart
from them being vaguely in the right
ballpark everything else about this is
made up that graph is made up it doesn't
look that nice and simple in reality but
I'm kind of hoping that we're heading
toward this spot where you know the
curve is starting to slow down and it
doesn't look like a crazy exponential
thing that's out of control now I want
to use this kind of made-up set of data
to try and understand this fundamental
theorem of calculus use it as an example
use it as a context for which to make
sense of this and I kind of want to
guide us through this by having a think
about a very simple and foundational
question as the name kind of suggests
and that is what's the total number of
new cases on the basis of this graph
which will interpret together between
now which I'm just going to call day 67
and some future time like say Deb's day
71 that's visible on my graph what's the
total number of new cases in that
limited period of time I want to have a
look at this graph and it isn't all that
dissimilar to the kinds of graphs you
actually have been seeing thrown around
the news how would we answer that
question about the total number of new
cases however we answer that on the
basis of this graph well it's not meant
to be a rhetorical question I'm sort of
trying to stall a little bit and buy
time for you if you're drawing a rough
copy of this graph in your own work book
have a think about this I'm trying to
compare day 67 with day 71 and you can
see both of those on the horizontal I
guess we'd call it the time axis down
the bottom how would we use this graph
to get an answer to that question okay
so while you're drawing let me try and
fill in a little bit right the
difference from day 67 to day 71
it's had an increase obviously so we can
work out well where do we start and how
far did we rise okay where do we start
how far did we rise so to work out where
we started I'm gonna go to day 67 on the
horizontal axis I'm gonna draw it up
oops
like with a highlighter and we're going
to draw it up toward the graph and see
where it collides there is my point of
intersection and I've given you nice
neat numbers here
part of why they're so artificially
simple just so that we don't get
confused by the arithmetic and it maps
over to 6000 so let's just suppose that
there's 6000 total cases of the
coronavirus in australia on day 67 and
then we just have to look forward in
time to what this projected model tells
us on day 71 I'm going to do exactly the
same thing I'm going up from the bottom
here you can see I'm going to collide on
the graph at this point over here and
again reading over to the left to our
vertical axis it tells me alright I
apparently am expecting I should have
11,000 cases by that time so the numbers
here are not immensely complicated
what's the total number of new cases the
answer would be let's see here I'll just
write it in the middle of the graph so
you can see it the total number of cases
would be 11,000 take away the 6,000 that
we already had at day 67 so not
complicated numbers 5,000 is the answer
we come up with now you might think well
this is a very rudimentary question it's
pretty basic what is there to gain like
what does this have to do with calculus
well in mathematics all the way through
like we've been teaching you algebra
trigonometry differentiation all the
rest one of the primary mechanisms we
use to understand something better is to
look at the same object from different
perspectives when you look at the same
object from different perspectives you
always gain insight you see it from a
different side and you think oh there
are things I didn't notice about this
before so what I want to do is look at
this same perspective and I'd love you
to draw a graph underneath this
underneath this sort of Cartesian plane
looking thing which looks very similar
it's going to have the same days across
the bottom it'll have a similar kind of
vertical axis as well and what I want to
think about is what we know from
differential calculus everything we know
in integral calculus for a long way has
been built on what we learned from
derivatives and differentiation so what
I'd love you to do is draw a new graph
of this without the same blue plot on it
and in this case we're actually going to
draw the derivative so to fill in the
gaps this is kind of what I am talking
about this is the same set of axes you
can see I've got days since the first
confirmed case and the same time line
that I had before
now I want to think about well how is
this situation changing over time not
what is the total but what about one of
the new cases day by a days so I'm
looking for a rate of change I guess we
would call this left hand on this
vertical axis I should say I guess we'd
call it something like the projected new
cases per day the projected number of
cases that come up each day not a
cumulative total but you know how many
did we count up this day that we didn't
know had Crona virus before so let me
just write that in for you and this is
the projected number of new cases now
one of the reasons why I gave you such
like I said an unofficial a simple graph
from before is so that we can just read
off of that graph what numbers should go
on to here so I'm actually going to go
back up to that graph and let's have a
look at it together if you have a look
there's clearly two different parts to
the graph there's the earlier situation
which is quite steep and then thankfully
in this projected model it starts to
level off and become a bit shallower so
I'm going to look at each one of those
in turn firstly let's have a look at the
first part from day 67 in fact even a
little bit before day 67 and then it
sort of stops at day 68 that's where
there's kind of this bend in the graph
have a look carefully and I'm gonna zoom
in just so you can see it as clearly as
possible have a look clearly and tell me
if you can see what is the gradient of
this straight line in this portion of
the graph when you change one day how
much do you increase in the number of
cases and I'm going to go ahead and type
it in the chat I can see all of the
comments coming up can anyone tell me
what the gradient of that first portion
of the line should be okay I'm seeing a
few numbers in here okay a lot of
numbers Kevin I get it thank you
I'm interested look look quickly look at
the units guys have a look at the
vertical axis and how it goes up each
time okay yes thank you Lawrence all
right so
what is gradient Brandon is rise over
run so if we have a look at the rise for
one unit right if I'm running one unit
from left to right
what's the rise that corresponds to that
well when you go from day 67 to day 68
as Laurens and Jason have identified it
rises from 6,000 to 8,000 cases so
that's a gradient of 2000 or 2000 over
one I guess is the most technical way to
say it before day 67 you've got a teeny
bit of graph there but you can see it's
a straight line it's continuous okay so
if i zoom back out now let's go to our
new graph where we're going to show the
derivative and what we want is for this
early portion term but just before day
67 through day 67 and into day 68 we
want to show that that has a gradient of
2000 so let's have a look here